وبمناسبه الحديث عن ماسك فاكيد يعني حضوره
لكاس العالم مو هو الخبر الوحيد اللي يخصه
صحيح هو في الدوحه كان بيتفرج على
المباراه بس قال لي الدنيا في تويتر عادي
زي العاده يعني فا قصه امس بدات لما حساب
تويتر سبورت او دعم تويتر اعلن عن سياسه
جديده اشعلت غضب على جدل على انتقادات على
اللي تبغوه يعني سياسه عنوانها الترويج
للمنصات الاخرى على تويتر فالشركه جالس في
تغريده انه بتقدر طبعا او بتقدر طبعا انه
في كثير مستخدمين مشتركين بمناصات
اجتماعيه اخرى لكن نحن نشر اي محتوى في
روابط او اسماء مستخدمين للمنصات الاخرى
مثل فيسبوك او انستغرام او تروس سوشي
غيرها عموما كل من الصوت معروف انه في
الجروب المسحقاتها بتقلل ظهور اي محتوى في
ترويش لمنصات اخرى لكن من النهائي بهذا
الشكل ما في وهذا كان سبب موجه انتقادات
وجدل وقادها مؤسس تويتر ورئيس الشركه
السابق جاك دورسي اللي على التغريده بكلمه
واحده وقال وايد ليه وغير جاك ملايين
احتجوا ينتقدوا هذا الشيء هذا لتراجع سريع
في حساب تويتر سكوت حذف التغريده والبيان
وماسك وضح في حسابه هو رد على سؤال احدهم
وقال انه راح يصير تعديل على السياسه
والحظر راح يكون للحسابات اللي راح تخصص
بشكل اساسي ووحيد كل يعني تغريدات هذه
الترويج لمنافسين غرد ماسك كمان وقال انه
من الان فصاعدا اي تغيير على سياسه رئيسيه
راح يوضع للتصويت قبل اقراره وقال بعتذر
وما راح يصير كده ثاني ويبدا انه ماسك ما
كذب بخبر وخصوص الاستطلاعات قبل اي قرار
مهم وهذه المره الاستطلاع كان الاستفتاء
على مصيره يعني قرار في غايه الاهميه وهذا
الشيء كان مفاجاه غير متوقع فنشر استطلاع
للراي طلب من متابعينه ويصوتوا على انه
يبقى في تويتر رئيس
وعد الجميع انه راح يلتزم بنتيجه
الاستطلاع ايش ما كانت وبالفعل فوق 17
مليون شخص صوتوا على الاستطلاع خلال ساعات
وكانت النتيجه مثل المشرفين قدامكم اكثر
من 57% صوتوا نعم تنحى
و42.5 صوتوا لا خليك ماسك بعد ما نشر
الاستطلاع غرد برسالك صار شافوها يعني
رساله مبطنه للمصوتين واستخدم مقوله
انجليزيه شهيره ترجمتها انه تكون حذرا مما
تتمنى لانه من الممكن انه تحصل عليه او
يتحقق لك وتغريده ثاني حملت رساله ثانيه
مبطنه كمان فغرد وقال لنفسهم في السلطه
والقوه هم اقل ناس يستاهلوها يعني صواريخ
يمين وشمال جالس ب- يطلقها بس كيف راح
يتعامل مع الصاروخ اللي ضربه هو موضوع
الاستفتاء هذا خلونا نتناقش مع ضيفنا
المحرر التقني في انتفندا عربيه عبد الله
السبع اهلا فيك معنا عبد الله خلينا نبتدي
من موضوع الاستفتاء على
بقاءه في رئاسه تويتر من عدمه صوت في ال-
اا الاستفتاء
انا ديمقراطي الى الان مصر صراحه
تويتر طيب قول لي يعني معقول احد يعمل
استفتاء على نفسه ويخسر بنفس الشكل طيب
تكلمت عن هذا الموضوع ان هدفهم من هذا
التصويت انه يكون امرين اذا اذا تنحى هو
بطلب من مستثمريه تسلم لانهم قاعدين
يشوفون حاليا ان همم رئاسه تويتر رجعت
تاثر جدا كبير على مستقبل ااه زي ما
تلاحقون في الايام الماضيه خف همم على
قولتهم بروز تسلم في العالم بشكل كامل
اسهمها قاعد تعاني في الفتره الماضيه من
بعد استحواذ الى مماسك على تويتر بشكل
مباشر فلذلك مستثمرين مستثمرين تسلى شويه
غاضبين
يرجونا الاسلام
يرجع يقود تسلم مره ثانيه بنفسها حتى يرجع
الوهج عليها بخصوص تويتر همم تويتر وموضوع
فشل في حال ان نجح وهو يثبت العالم سياسات
الناجحه في الموضوع هو سلاح ذو حدين فشل
قال لهم اساسا مطلوب مني اني اروح وتسلا
وان نجح قال لهم انتم اللي اخترتوني يلا
خلاص انا مستمر لكن حتى لو همم تنازل او
تنهى تويتر
وطلبات راح تكون منفذه بحكم انه هو المالك
همم الوحيد لمن هذه المنصه فلذلك حتى لو
كان رئيس مجلس اداره او صفه مختلفه
تكون قراراتها لها تاثير مباشره على منصه
تويتر
يسمع ينفذ كل طلباته بس لما تصير شيء يزعل
الناس يقول لهم بس هذا الرئيس حق تويتر
يعني فممكن تكون يعني ايه
هي اللي تتوقع همم على قولتهم الضرب على
اي قرار
هو يطلع في صيغه المواطن وينقذ الناس من
قرارات هذا الرئيس ما توقع ان سياسه قد
تكون ناجحه من قبل الناس راح اضع شخص ياخذ
الضرب ياخذ كل شيء وبعدين قرار انا اطلع
زي ما صار امس يوم نزله القرار ايقاف ال-
ال- الترويج من الصوت
السياسه هذه
السياسه بشكل ذكي بده انه الان استوعب انه
لازم يلعب همم يسوي حركات اكثر بس على
سيره هذه الموضوع اللي قلته حق الروابط
ومن الروابط يعني ايش يكون صار يعني ايش
يكون خطر على بالهم انه يمنعوا اي شيء من
منصات الثانيه
طيب لازم نعرف انه تويتر قاعد تعاني من
فتره حساسه فلو الناس اتجهت الى منصه
ثانيه ابتعاظا من القرارات الجديده او غير
هذا رح يؤثر بشكل سلبي على دخله تويتر
منصه مجانيه
تقل الاعلانات تقل الارباح لذلكم
للمعلوميه كل من رصات التواصل اجتماعيه
حاليا تمنع الترويجري
حاليا
رابط السناب شات تلقى يرفضوا مثل هذا
الموضوع سناب شات ايضا لو نشرت فيديو حطيت
رابط انستغرام تلقاهم يقللون من ظهور
المقطع
انه يحذفوا
هم كل من اصوات تواصل بطريقه باخرى تحارب
الترويجري من الصوت ثانيه فلذلك الشيء
طبيعي
وتوقع انه تويتر قاعد تقول انتم
الانستغرام وسناب شات تمنعوني موجود عندكم
في المثل وهو امر طبيعي يتوقع ولا هو شيء
همم في مشكله جدا كبيره
[موسيقى]